i do think the passion for sports
has waned and faded i see it in myself
i don't like
or respect the athletes the way that i
used to and it's never
it's never that i used to think these
guys were the smartest guys on the
planet
but i also didn't think they were the
dumbest guys on the planet or the
easiest to control or totally controlled
by group think and social media i didn't
think they were frauds and phonies who
were just willing to say and do anything
to stay in the good graces of social
media and the elite overlords and that's
what i think now
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
sports analyst a culture critic and host
of the fairly new show fearless on blaze
tv jason whitlock welcome to round two
on the reuben report
i thought this was round three but maybe
i'm wrong maybe you know your interviews
are so long they just feel like two
rounds
oh he's starting in with a hook i'm
pretty sure this is round two
i think it's round two
all right well i got another shot you're
the sports guy you guys love stats you
guys love stats you sports people let me
throw another jab before you get started
i just want everybody to know watching
at home
uh a month ago or three weeks ago i
asked dave to come on my show to consent
to an interview
dave puts me off
i'm on vacation i'm doing this i'm doing
that i don't and somehow
i end up on dave's show
before he comes on my show dave doesn't
say anything about you know i'll return
the favor or anything like that
it's just day being day well i guess so
here i am
i just wanted to get through this one
make sure it works out okay we're off to
a good start and then uh i'll gladly uh
swing by over there
all right
all right
well i'm probably gonna
talk about the stuff i want to talk with
you about i'm probably going to talk
about it to now
it'll be over we'll just run a replay of
this interview on my show but anyway go
ahead i'm sorry i'm going to shut up and
listen to you it's your show i know
i have a feeling we'll find some other
things to talk about but but there's
actually a ton i want to talk to you
about because when i had you on and i'm
pretty sure it's only been once but when
i had you on in studio in la a couple
years back it's probably a good three
years ago already i mean time flies
especially these days um you know it
sort of felt like sports was in the
midst of this weird meltdown but it
didn't feel like it had fully melted
down and the racialization of everything
and the gender and football is gay and
all of the stuff that is out there now
uh so i guess my first question really
is what's your general take on what has
happened
to sports in general in the last couple
years i think i told you that i don't
watch anything anymore i do not watch
professional sports anymore that's very
sad to me i just can't take it anymore
dave i just had this discussion on my
show on wednesday
about because the nfl right now is
bragging about hey
week one ratings uh were up seven
percent over a year ago and the nfl is
back and look at the tv ratings and and
and what i'm arguing is like the nfl
in particular is america's comfort food
and america is in desperate need of
comfort right now because of
covid
uh
and because of the racial meltdown we've
had we're looking for anything that
reminds us of the way things used to be
and so
i think the initial kind of rush back to
sports and football and filling up
stadiums and let's have fun
i i think that's what's happening people
are looking they want some nostalgia
they want some comfort
i do think and and i argued this on
wednesday and and uncle jimmy and the
guests we had on dennis evans they both
pushed back against me but i do think
the passion for sports
has waned and faded i see it in myself
i don't like
or respect the athletes the way that i
used to and it's never
it's never that i used to think these
guys were the smartest guys on the
planet
but i also didn't think they were the
dumbest guys on the planet or the
easiest to control or totally controlled
by group think and social media i didn't
think they were frauds and phonies who
were just willing to say and do anything
to stay in the good graces of social
media and the elite overlords and that's
what i think now so i still watch the
sports
i don't feel as good about the athletes
and eventually and i made this analogy
it's like the old bb king song the
thrill is gone
and
sometimes when you're ending a
relationship you go through this
part where you're not quite separated
you're still living in the same house
you're still going through the motions
but everybody knows it's over
and that's kind of how i feel about uh
professional sports i still watch i
still somewhat i love them i love the
games
but the passion for the athletes just
isn't the same as it used to be and
eventually
i'll just spend less and less time with
sports
on a personal note how much does that
suck for you i mean not only is this
your job and you got into this stuff
because you love it i mean i was never a
sports analyst but i grew up watching
the same games you were watching like
loving that stuff and it kind of sucks
it kind of when i'm flipping on youtube
and i'm watching old nba games when it
wasn't political and then they show me a
new one i'm just like no i just don't
want to do it and it kind of sucks no it
it sucks big time dave uh because for
someone like me
who there's two things that have shaped
my world view
the church my grandmother and mother
raised me in in football and playing
sports because i in high school i played
at track and field play a little
basketball intramural or whatever play
foot i was in the sports and the values
taught in sports and the values taught
in my church
there was great synergy and alignment
between them i'm looking at sports
betray all of those values
and it irritates the heck out of me
it bothers me immensely and so
this sucks to see something this central
to your core beliefs
completely pivot and give in to marxism
and
uh
you know authoritarian everybody must
get the facts or you face these harsh
penalties of i just don't like any of it
and yeah it just and
it sucks big time
so the newest thing speaking of the vax
in the last couple days now the nba has
reached a deal somehow even though they
have over a hundred employees that the
players will not have to be vaccinated i
don't understand how that makes any
sense i'm not for mandating vaxxes just
just so you know that uh but they've
they've gotten this exemption but it
appears that the people who go to the
games will have to be vaccinated now i'm
fairly certain nba players might sweat
on each other spit on each other are do
they have some sort of protections we
don't know about
they don't
this sounds
similar to what the nfl you don't have
to be vaccinated in the nfl
but you do face all these different set
of rules that the vaccinated players
don't face
that sounds like what the nba is going
to do it's stupid it makes no sense it's
no different than last year when no one
was vaccinated they're all in arena
the coach is wearing a mask for no
reason he pulls it down every time he
wants to really be heard and say
anything important and it was just it
was the masquerade theater that that
we've been seeing for the past 18 months
and they were doing it in nba so a guy
has to sit in a different place in the
locker room maybe he has to fly
somewhere differently on a plane but
when you get out on the court sweat and
bump into each other and slap high five
and sit next to each other on the bench
sweaty as you want to be
that's all fine but when we go in this
locker room go sit over here because
you're not vaccinated it's just stupid
and i'm i'm pretty sure you've heard the
same crazy rumors that i've heard about
when the nba was in the bubble right it
was called the bubble about all of the
girls that were getting smuggled into
the bubble like it's not like these
people did not live and i'm pretty sure
it didn't become a coveted super
spreader event
dave
and i hope i'm not cracking an
inappropriate joke i i don't i can't but
i'm not sure if you're aware i'm not
sure if you're aware but i've talked to
dr fauci about this personally
but
the covet virus cannot live inside of a
vagina
so
when the women were coming into the
bubble
and and you know their vagina is
completely pure and
bacteria free covert free and so that
was perfectly understandable and safe
dave
i'm just going to make note of that
kovid cannot live in the vagina okay
well we got our promo out of you
whitlock
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell